nochmal wasser noch mal ein tragisches
unglück diesmal auf mallorca dort geht
ein 54-jähriger schwimmen und ertrinkt
vor den augen seines elf jahre alten
sohnes
osterzeit ist urlaubszeit und das auch
auf malle aber bereits jetzt der erste
badetoten ein 54 jähriger deutscher
urlauber besuchte mit seinem elfjährigen
sohn den strand und ging trotz
schlechten wetters und
die bucht ist an ideen machst im osten
der balearischen urlaubsinsel mallorca
wie touristen ganz besonders an gilt als
eine besonders romantische bucht
strahlend blaues wasser goldgelber sand
strand doch die idylle trügt denn auch
das gehört zu sechst an ideen maß hohe
wellen und starke strömungen die wurden
jetzt einem 54 jährigen vater zum
verhängnis und das vor den augen seines
elfjährigen sohnes als der urlauber
versuchte wieder ans ufer zu gelangen
scheiterte er aufgrund der starken
strömung laut augenzeugen er trank er
noch im wasser sein sohn musste alles
mit ansehen
jede hilfe kam zu spät eine augenzeugin
beobachtete das drama und versuch den
familienvater noch zu retten sie wählt
den notruf
ich habe auch noch gesehen wie die
person versucht hat sich selbst an den
felsen aus dem wasser zu ziehen aber es
gelang ihm nicht es kam eine hohe welle
die den mann mitriss und unter das
wasser drückt anschauen der körper des
mannes auf der oberfläche ich glaube ich
sah von hier aus dem kopf dann war die
polizei schon vor ort ein kellner und
ein koch rannten noch zur hilfe auch
mein mann half die leiche aus dem wasser
zu ziehen
es ist nicht das erste mal dass an den
stränden der idyllischen insel urlauber
in den tod gerissen werden
die rettungsschwimmer sind erst ab dem
ersten mai von 10 bis 19 uhr hier am
strand
so war es vermutlich auch für die beiden
schwestern vor genau sieben monaten
starben hanna und vanessa weggerissen in
den tod allen urlaubern rate in
schlechtem wetter und hohen wellengang
nicht ins wasser zu gehen doch auch
diese warnung kommt für den deutschen
urlauber zu spät